empezó a las nueve y media de la mañana
en el comité de apropiaciones que es el
que define todo el tema presupuestal en
la cámara de representantes- cuenta con
la mayoría dado que son los demócratas
que tienen la mayoría también en la
cámara baja de este paquete de ayuda de
1,9 19 billones de dólares que entre
otras cosas incluye cheques para los
estadounidenses de 1400 dólares incluye
también 600 millones de dólares
aproximadamente para hacer frente al
quabit y agilizar la vacuna el proceso
de distribución de la vacuna y también
crédito para las pequeñas y medianas
empresas lo que no incluye es el aumento
de 15 dólares la hora que querían los
demócratas impulsar en este plan de
reactivación económica porque los
republicanos están diciendo que van
contra las reglas del senado que no
pueden simplemente tratar de meter ahí
un aumento salarial así entonces los
demócratas lo que están
ésta tiene una contrapropuesta y quieren
penalizar las empresas en eeuu quién
y paguen los 15 dólares la obra como es
como fue la propuesta inicial de los
demócratas bueno y si todo sigue su
curso cristóbal para cuando podría
sancionarse el proyecto
si ahora entonces pasaría la próxima
semana a la cámara alta al senado allá
se hacen las revisiones se hace la
votación y como pasa como una ley de
reconciliación luego a necesitar si no
la mayoría simple es decir 51 votos los
demócratas con la vicepresidenta kamala
harris como presidenta del senado pues
ajustan esos 51 votos y entonces la ley
sería aprobada en la cámara alta pasaría
entonces a la cámara baja para una
revisión final y después a la oficina
del presidente se espera que para el 8
de marzo ya esté firmado la semana
perdón del 8 de marzo ya esté firmada
esta ley y los americanos entonces
puedan empezar a recibir las ayudas
económicas gracias cristóbal